I'm joined today by dr. Elizabeth
Englander who's a professor of
psychology and the director of the
Massachusetts aggression reduction
Center at Bridgewater State University
which is one of the leading research
centers in the u.s. that looks at
cyberbullying so first question I think
is when we look at cyberbullying in what
ways do we need to look at it
differently than in-person bullying and
in what ways is it the same if there are
any well there are some differences I
think the difference is primarily are
usually around how people use digital
technology when they communicate so for
example saying something online is
really not the same as saying it in
person there's often a lot of
information missing and we noticed that
in our subjects there are a lot of
misunderstandings that lead to problems
between kids online as well as things
that sort of get blown up out of
proportion but having said that I think
it's really important to not think about
cyber bullying and bullying as being
completely separate I think they usually
interact with each other in kids lives
today and online is really sort of just
another place where kids see their
friends and so there's really a lot
going on online that also happens in
school and it tends to go back and forth
I don't know if you've followed at all
this situation called gamergate that's
been going on which focuses a lot around
online a harassment that different
groups allege they've been the victims
of or that different people have been
perpetrators of and one of the
interesting narratives that has
surrounded it has been that some say if
gamergate rather than being an online
thing was an in-person thing you
wouldn't have almost any of the
harassment because by their very nature
many of the video gamers that are
involved in this issue are not the types
of people who would have the
personalities to participate in
in-person bullying I'm curious whether
you have any thoughts on that and again
I don't know how much you know
specifically about this gamergate thing
but generally how does that sound to you
that sounds very plausible to me one of
the things that changes when people go
online there's a few things
change but one of the important things
that changes is that people tend to
become very disinhibited so they'll say
and do things that they usually would
not do in person and there can be a
couple of different reasons for that
sometimes when you're online you
interact with other people who agree
with you primarily and that can sort of
embolden you
whereas in person you can't always
control so much who's listening to you
and who's talking with you and so people
tend to be a little more tentative but
also online it's there's a very strong
tendency when you're interacting with a
machine that has a person attached to
the other end to sort of forget that
there are people at the other end and to
over focus on yourself so a user might
say and do things in an effort to maybe
impress their friends or to look as
though they're really intelligent or
really informed and they sort of forget
that there's another person at the other
end and we see that all the time I want
to talk a little bit about the the
victims of physical and cyber bullying
but before we get to that when we think
about the reasons why someone may bully
or harass others do we see any
difference in sort of the catalyst or
impetus for bullying and harassment
online versus in person well it it does
strike me that a lot of the online
incidents that we study a higher
proportion of them seem to be a little
more inadvertent it's not that people do
them by accident
kids are still may be mean to somebody
they may say something mean on purpose
but they often don't intend for it to be
repeated quite so much they may not
intend for it to be emphasized they may
not intend for it to have quite the
impact it has and because they can't see
the other person they don't know what
kind of impact it's having and so they
can't sort of adjust their narrative so
they're really in person you see a lot
more things that are more deliberate
maybe more thought-out
but online there seems to be a lot more
communication problems that happen
because something gets out of hand or a
child starts a rumor and suddenly
everyone's talking about it maybe they
didn't intend that to happen so we
really see a difference in intent online
a lot of the time the impact of bullying
on the victim can really vary
drastically even for for in-person
bullying or online bullying are there
any more general observations that you
have about how victims of in-person
bullying may be differently affected
than victims of online bullying well
that's kind of controversial at the
moment okay there's not a lot of good
data that really cuts it either way very
clearly there are some studies that have
found that in-person bullying is more
impactful and there are other studies
that have found that what happens online
is really much more impactful we do know
that some people are much more resilient
to these kinds of problems there are
some there are some kids who really seem
to let this stuff slide off their back
but many others are very impacted and
it's it's important to note that these
kinds of social attacks are really
associated with problems like depression
and anxiety and and social problems and
academic and work problems and and they
have a very significant cost but it can
be really hard to predict what's going
to impact a particular person the most
so if you have one person that person
might say oh well you know I was much
more impacted but what happened in
school but another child might say oh no
it wasn't in school that was big the big
thing was having you know an
embarrassing photo posted that everyone
in the world could see so we really
don't know very much about the
difference and why it is that sometimes
one thing seems to hit kids harder and
sometimes the other thing I mean I can
certainly imagine how if you are at home
on a computer you might have more of an
expectation of immunity to bullying than
if you were in a public place with other
people physically around you right
I could understand feeling like hey if
I'm at home my parents are home I'm just
on my computer you might be less
prepared or expecting to be the victim
of bullying yeah you might feel safer
you might feel like mmm you know I don't
know if if children today really
imagined that bullying only happens in
school anymore I think that children
today are pretty aware that it happens
online so they don't I don't think they
have the expectation that it's only
gonna happen in school the way kids
maybe 5 or 10 years ago might have kids
today are very very aware of cyber
bullying on the whole but having said
that it does feel different it may feel
much more invasive when you're at home
and cyber bullying does have the unique
characteristic that it doesn't depend on
where you are so it doesn't stop at the
end of school it can go on all the time
and that the relentless nature of that
is really hard probably the thing that
we see that hurts kids the most is when
these kinds of it social problems are
repeated when somebody goes after them
again and again it's not the one time
things that seem to stick with kids it's
the times when a social problem happens
over and over again that are really
important last thing I want to talk
about is sort of a pragmatic approach to
getting would be bullies or former
bullies to stop bullying you know we've
talked to a lot of different experts in
child development who who point out the
sort of longer term problems that can be
caused by a more authoritarian parenting
style and so I'm curious as to whether
you what what observations you might
have about effective techniques for
getting bullies not to bully our
punishments our harsh punishments really
the way to go or does it correlate more
with what we've seen about the problems
with a sort of authoritarian response
right well there's also no definitive
answer on that I mean we really don't
understand exactly why people are
aggressive I mean we have ideas in
general we know for example that you
know being pushed around or bullied you
self might lead you to bully others or
having been a victim yourself might be
really important but we can't look at an
individual person and say this is why he
did that
sure what we do know excuse me what we
do know is that when parents take these
things very seriously when they talk to
kids about the idea that there are
really no excuses for being cruel to
other people it doesn't matter if you're
mad it doesn't matter if you're
frustrated there's you never have to
write to do this it's never okay
but those kinds of messages seem to be
most effective and of course they're
really most effective when parents model
that themselves so when parents
themselves aren't cruel to their kids
are cruel to other people and they
really show their kids how to behave to
others we've been speaking with dr.
Elizabeth Englander professor of
psychology and director of the
Massachusetts aggression reduction
Center at Bridgewater State University
super important topic especially as more
and more of life is lived out online or
digitally this is certainly not going to
be an issue that goes away so thanks so
much for talking to us about it thanks
for having me